this episode is sponsored by Ren a
website where you can calculate your
carbon emissions you can also sign up to
make a monthly contribution to offset
your emissions or support rainforest
protection projects by clicking our Link
in the description
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in our episode last week we introduced
you to a particular type of relationship
between two creatures called epibiosis
which is when one organism takes up
residence on the surface of another and
we asked which one you would prefer to
be the one living on or the one being
lived upon and there are plenty of pros
and cons to either lifestyle but these
interactions can vary a lot based on the
species involved so we promised to dive
a little deeper into one specific
example of epibiosis where it might be a
little bit easier to decide because
choosing wrong means death
this is Kendra forus a ciliate that
James our master of microscopes had been
searching for receiving samples from all
over the world in the hopes of finding
it gliding around and finally it turned
up and some sand samples he received
from the Adriatic coast of Italy when
you look at it this country for us
probably doesn't seem particularly
special it's just slowly gliding along
the slide looking a bit more like a worm
than a fascinating case study in
epibiosis but there are two things that
the kentroforos is famous for the first
is its lack of a mouth and the second is
its coat of bacteria as we zoom in you
can see those bacteria poking out on one
side of the ciliate's body scientists
have actually estimated that one kinter
Forest can have around 4 500 individual
bacteria living on it at least 15
kentroforo species have been described
but they can look very different from
one another some are like ours flat and
ribbon-like others are built more like a
tube some have their bacterial coat laid
out on one side of their body While
others tuck the bacteria into Pockets
made out of their own self the fact that
these different species look so
different from one another and that the
only things really tying them together
were mouthlessness and bacterial
companions meant that scientists had to
ask the question are these different
species actually related it would not be
the first or last time that we'd been
LED astray by a few coincidental
similarities but when they studied the
kentroforosis DNA they found that the
species are in fact related to each
other suggesting that they may have
evolved this relationship with their
bacterial friends long ago and spread
that partnership all over the world
when you look at the bacteria on their
own you can see their rod shape more
clearly these bacteria are primarily
thiotrophs meaning that they live on
sulfur when researchers dug into the
genetics of these bacteria they found
that they were all members of the same
clade gamma proteobacteria a type of
bacteria that includes more famous
sulfur bacteria like begiatoa but
additional work found evidence of
another type of bacteria in that coat as
well called
mirabaculaciai a branch of bacteria that
includes residents of our own guts
now we mentioned earlier that James
found these Kendra for us and samples
that came from the Adriatic coast and
that's no accident kentroforos are
usually found in Marine sediments and
that is thanks in part to the
thyotrophic bacteria that live on their
surface their relationship reminds us a
bit of paramecium bursaria and the green
algae chlorella that live as
endosymbionts inside of vacuoles
specially designed to hold them
chlorella love Sun using it to drive
their photosynthesis so that they can
make their own food and so to suit the
needs of their internal residence
paramecium bursaria are also drawn to
well-lit areas
it is an exchange that works very well
for both the algae and the paramecium
the algae gets the safety of the
paramecium's body and the paramecium
gets some of the nutritional benefit of
whatever the algae has made the Kendra
forest's relationship with their
thyotrophic bacteria is similar except
that the bacteria live on the
kentroforos instead of inside them and
instead of being drawn to light the
cantroforos are drawn instead to that
band of water that hovers above the
sediment where oxygen is low and there's
just enough hydrogen sulfide for the
bacteria to convert into food by letting
themselves be drawn to these areas the
kentroforos benefits as well taking in
some of the metabolites made by the
bacteria and it seems that this exchange
has paid off enough for both the
bacteria and the contraforos the
kentroforo Sicilia is distributed in
such a way to make sure that there are
specific places kept free and clear here
for their surface tenants and the
pockets we described some Kendra foro
species as having maximized the amount
of space available for the bacteria to
attach themselves to Meanwhile the
Kendra forosis bacteria divide in a way
that is not typically seen but that
makes sense when you remember how it
lives typically a rod-shaped bacteria
would divide down the middle along its
shorter axis but these bacteria tear
apart down the longer axis breaking
apart into a sort of v-shape that then
splits in two and why would it do that
because it lets them stay attached to
their host as they divide hooked on
through the root of the V until it's
ready to completely separate into two
now this all seems to be a fairly
balanced well-managed relationship of
the microcosmos the bacteria get access
to sulfur the kentroforos gets access to
nutrients what could possibly go wrong
well a lot if you are the bacteria
because sometimes the cantroforos gets
hungry too hungry
a few metabolites from their bacterial
buddies just aren't enough anymore but
the bacteria themselves well that is a
nice snack to have on hand the
kentroforos may be mouthless but it is
not harmless it has a trick up its
sleeve
phagocytosis it simply absorbs the
bacteria into itself and begins to eat
in some descriptions of the relationship
between the kentroforos and bacteria the
scientists Bland Finley and Tom finchel
have used the phrase kitchen Garden to
describe them which is a quaint image
from the kentroforus's point of view
it's kind of sweet after all to imagine
the ciliate raising a field of bacteria
fertilizing it with trips through anoxic
Waters and tending to its needs
but from the bacteria's point of view it
must feel like a bit of a betrayal like
the whole ground beneath their feet just
opened up and swallowed them whole and
in our imagination that seems like a far
worse place to exist if you were to ask
the simple question who would you rather
be the answer here feels like an easy
one that seems much more appealing to be
the creature who chooses to consume the
other not the one who goes from friend
to phagocytos without warning but maybe
we are being too human about this the
relationship between these bacteria and
the syriad has gone on for a long time
covering oceans on opposite sides of the
planet there is something about this
that must work for the bacteria even if
we do not have the capacity to imagine
it working for us perhaps there is
something to this life attached to the
side of another creature's body
surviving as countless copies of
yourself endure
perhaps there's something to all that
makes sense when it's all that you've
known and perhaps it is our life our way
of imagining ourselves as whole complete
individuals rather than as a single note
in the broader Symphony of our species
that is truly bizarre
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us and thank you again to
Ren for sponsoring this episode Ren is a
website where you can calculate your
carbon emissions then offset them by
funding projects like ones that help
improve the transparency and scientific
Integrity of carbon removal and climate
Solutions through open data tools and
Leadership we will need a lot of
different approaches to stop the climate
crisis and this is one way that you can
learn more about your carbon
contribution and take some action you'll
answer a few questions about your
lifestyle and they'll also show you ways
you can start reducing your carbon
emissions now no one can reduce their
footprint to zero yet but using Ren you
can offset what you have left once you
sign up you'll receive updates from the
tree planting rainforest protection and
other projects you support and we have
partnered with Ren to plant 10
additional trees for the first 100
people who sign up using the link in our
description
the people on your screen right now are
the folks who make it possible for us to
scour the world for the microbes we want
to share with the world this is a big
beautiful planet and I think part of
what makes a living here worthwhile is
paying a lot of concentrated attention
to it and these people here on the
screen I think they agree and if you'd
like to become one of them you can go to
patreon.com journey to micro where we
have a bunch of cool perks if you want
to see more from our master of
microscopes James Weiss you can check
out jam and germs on Instagram and if
you want to see more from us there's
always a subscribe button somewhere
nearby
[Music]